Mayon mobile are inspecting a 80 to 1
scale floorplan of their new house the
dimensions of the living room in the
scaled plan are 4 centimeters 4
centimeters by 5 centimeters by 5
centimeters right over here what is the
area the area of the living room in the
real world so they gave us these
dimensions right over here this is the
scale plan and then we could figure out
these dimensions in the real world by
looking at the scale factor right here
it's an 80 to 1 scale floorplan and we
can assume that the house is much bigger
than the floor plan so the 80 for every
80 units in the house for every 80 units
in the house that represents one unit on
the floor planned floor plan so if we
had 80 meters in the house that would be
represented as 1 meter on the floor plan
if we had 80 centimeters in the house
that would be represented by one
centimeter in the floor plan so whatever
what if it goes the other way around one
centimeter on the floor plan would
represent 80 centimeters in the house
and it's always important to do if this
confuses you just to always do a reality
check that the house should be bigger
than the floor plan so if the floor plan
for this dimension of our living room is
4 centimeters the actual house will be
80 times that and 80 times 4 is 320 let
me do that in that blue color is equal
to 300 and 20 centimeters 320
centimeters and we can do the same thing
for the length of the living room so 80
times 5 centimeters is going to get us
to is going to be 80 times 5 is 400
centimeters so we can figure out the
area of this room in centimeters if we
like it I guess we why not it might be
easier to convert to meters later so
let's see 400 centimeters times 320
centimeters let me write this down
400 times 320 let's think about it for
time
32 is going to be 120 +8 128 and I have
one two three zeroes one two three so
it's going to be a hundred and twenty
eight thousand one hundred and twenty
eight thousand centimeter squared 128
thousand centimeter squared now that's a
lot of square centimeters what would we
do if we wanted to convert it into
meters well we just have to figure out
how many square centimeters are there in
a square meter so let's think about it
this way a meter is equal to one meter
is equal to 100 centimeters so a square
meter a square meter so that's right
over there one meter squared would be
one meter by one meter which is the same
thing as 100 centimeters by a hundred
centimeters and so if you were to
calculate this area in centimeters a
hundred times 100 is ten thousand is
equal to ten thousand ten thousand
centimeters squared centimeters squared
so you have ten thousand square
centimeters for every square meter and
so if you wanted to convert a 128
thousand centimeters squared to meter
squared you would divide by ten thousand
so dividing that by ten thousand would
give us dividing it by ten thousand
would give us 12 twelve point eight
twelve point eight square meters now
another way you could have done it and
maybe this would have been easier is to
convert it up here instead of saying 400
centimeters times 320 centimeters you
say well 400 centimeters that's going to
be four meters that's going to be four
meters and 320 centimeters well that's
3.2 meters times 3.2 - and you say okay
four times 3.2 that is twelve point
eight square meters but either way the
area of the living room in the real
world in meter squared or square meters
is twelve point eight